leads to kind of longer-term rate one of
the things that we talked about last
time when we recorded was the idea of
the autonomous taxis right and you kind
of you know much farther out when I
asked for people that questions to send
in for you one of them was around this
idea of if that is the ultimate kind of
end state here and that's where a lot of
value gets created as well does it make
sense at any point over the short to
medium term for Tesla to create natural
ride-sharing app and start competing
with the ubers and lyft's of the world
or is it more continue to invest in R&D
continue to build out that actual
technology and then you back into the
fleet you know at some point in the
future well it's a great question from a
couple of angles first Tesla's ability
to produce is limited by the constraint
is management and so they need to build
out management and they are and so in
the meantime as they're revving up on
getting their management infrastructure
in place around the world Europe Asia
and so forth
here here Texas another one we do
believe that they are going to start
their own ride hailing service Elon has
hinted as such I think there was a
question on I think it was a recent
conference call but it could have been a
podcast where Elon said yeah it sounded
like a good idea usually when he says
that done you know now the reason it's
also a very good question is I think
uber and lyft are in a world of hurt
here and the reason for that is the way
that business was beginning to evolve is
you are getting these entrepreneurs who
are saying okay I'm gonna buy several
cars here and
and I'll buy the cars all on them and
populate them with writers well guess
what they they were on shoestring
margins probably in the early days
anyone in the early days so a lot of
them are going to be out of business you
know they'll lose the cars and all of
that that and that's sad
so there is an opportunity here for
Tesla to come in and what that will do
it'll do two things that are very
important strategically for for Tesla
one it will increase their free cash
flow it's a very very profitable
business relative to their base business
today which is just producing cars
that's that they're just of producing
cars is you know a 25 to 30% growth
gross margin business and this is
probably that this one if it were their
own right ailing service would be north
of 50 percent the way they would
probably do it interestingly would be to
say to these former entrepreneurs you
know if you give us five thousand down
on a car we will let you become a part
of our fleet and you can pay down that
car by giving us a percentage of your
your fees the the take rate it would be
the take rate the take rate for uber and
lyft is you know 25 to 30 percent and we
think that's going down we think we
think Tesla's take rate could be much
higher because these owners would be
paying down their cars over time and
they'd be employed in this business so
it's a win-win for for both sides
it's also a win-win on in two ways for
Tesla one the free cash flow
the second is having a ride-hailing
service out there means they their
collection of data will go into
overdrive you know they'll be pushing
cars out that drive 50 60 % of the day
instead of
my Tesla at five percent of the day you
know so that I don't collect very many
miles per day for Tesla to inform it's
AI deep learning neural net systems
whereas these these these drivers would
be contributing a lot to the data yeah
it's super interesting another name that
you've been quite bullish on and
actually agree with is somewhat
underestimated is a square and what
they're doing in in the FinTech and
payment space maybe give us kind of your
thoughts on just like why so bullish on
that company and that we could talk to
you some of the intricacies or nuances
of it yeah and I'm gonna give a shout
out for to Max Friedrich who's our
analyst and we're just about to publish
a white paper on comparing venmo and
cash app to traditional banks and even
to each other you know
then Moe's a bit older than cash out and
and because of that cash app has some
advantages certainly in terms of its
agility and in terms of marketing
strategies and you know it's a it's a
more it's a younger it's a younger team
I would have to say and and we got a lot
of data you know from PayPal API you
know they they basically publish this
data so it's a very rich white paper in
terms of learning about these ecosystems
and learning the competitive advantages
that both PayPal venmo and cash app have
relative to banks so in the case you in
the case of square you know I just love
it because it it is really an abling you
know the lower income strata of this
economy anywhere from the lower income
to the highest income but really it's
much more meaningful to the unbanked and
if you look at where cash up really took
off first if you look at a map and you
compare it to an
GIC map of the unbanked and underbanked
part of the United States you'll see the
overlay is almost an exact match and so
that's how it started
and it started with these mom-and-pop
businesses really using the square
point-of-sale device to put on top of
their cell phone to actually do business
and so what can Square see unlike a bank
which can't maybe sees end of month or
end of quarter income statements square
sees every transaction that this
merchant may or has and can see the
cadence can see when business is good
when it's bad and what is some starting
to do now is say hey we see that you're
growing your business we can offer you a
working capital loan and guess what you
can pay that loan off as your business
you know daily you can pay a bit off you
know so it becomes a real time oh we see
you probably need more employees hey we
can help you with a payroll service and
then they will start infiltrating a
consumer base - which is part of the
employee base of this so it's cash app
gets added strength because it's
becoming part of a bigger ecosystem that
is proliferating first through the south
now it's moving up we're seeing it move
and and you'll see on the maps how it is
so the competitive advantage that these
companies have relative to banks I think
is going to destroy banks it's going to
turn them into commoditized utility I
mean there will be there there will be a
reason for banks but it's not gonna be
it's not gonna be the most profitable
reason there are for banks now